alosi maglia bonjour vous alors
directeur d'exploitation du vélodrome
ont nié alors on va se situer un petit
peu long mais on n'est pas loin de la
sortie de tout oui même à côté du entre
le rond point de la paix céleste et la
base de loisirs et la base de loisirs de
l'autre côté donc voilà pour les gens
qui ne devraient pas où ça se situer
alors on est on est à la mi septembre à
peu près vous êtes contourne
d'avancement des travaux on est très
content on est vraiment dans la dernière
ligne droite ce sera fini d'ici un mois
à peu près et puis après il ya toutes
les phases de d'homologation de sécurité
de finition qui vont qui vont intervenir
dans cours et on est très satisfait de
la livraison est prévue quoi 13 décembre
c'est un exact e mans la livraison du
bâtiment du constructeur vers la société
d'exploitation le 13 décembre et puis
dès le 13 janvier 2014 le grand public
pourra venir la visiter et découvrir le
vélodrome est ce que c'est un des envois
parlais tout à l'heure mais c'est un des
aspects de ce vélodrome c'est que ça va
être ouvert évidemment au public s'est
consacré au vélo mais pas seulement on
va en parler maintenant quelques
instants donc donc à partir de fin
janvier c'est ça les gens vous voient
revenir
visitez visiter faire du sport se
balader en accès direct avec la base de
loisirs voilà recréer une base de vie de
ce côté-là de l'autoroute quand vous dit
de faire du sport ou pour venir faire
quoi ba du vélo de piste déjà ils
pourront rouler ouvert exactement on
aura des coachs pour initier à la
pratique de la piste qui vont donc
n'importe quelle personne pourra venir
faire un baptême de piste sur la vision
olympique avec plaisir avec ces
traitements chez environ 40 degrés mais
vous verrez ça se fait assez bien vous
allez essayer
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de faire un
baptême de piste à à l'insep donc sur
une piste qui est quand même beaucoup
plus petit et j'irai que les sensations
sont assez intéressante et assez
déconcertante entre la difficulté
visuelle et la facilité avec laquelle on
roulait sur cette piste est très
impressionnant
ça se fait assez naturellement en fait
alors ce que je vous propose c'est pour
moi j'aimerais venir visiter l'intérieur
c'est le ballon à l'intérieur mais pour
ça il faut qu'on sait qu'ils peuvent
vous équipes minimes engagés au caire et
ont fait en y allant
laurent auneau du mali on arrive là
vraiment face à la piste 1 c'est là donc
je reviens à se passer dans le coeur de
l'enceinte incroyable on peut descendre
oui on peut descendre et vous allez
découvrir justement cette pente à 44°
qui fait frémir tout le monde donc n'a
égalé mais il ya des traverses beaucoup
pour qu'on puisse monter pour les
travaux mais ça va disparaître et veda
moi c'est extrêmement impressionnant
parce qu'on est impressionnés on est
comme ça qu on al impression vraiment de
basculer mais encore une fois cette la
vie la vitesse de la vitesse de
progression fait que l'on peut monter
plus ou moins osé jusqu'ici et où ils
peuvent monter tout en haut les
meilleurs sont même capables de
s'arrêter en plein milieu et de par un
système d' équilibre d'essayer de tenir
pour jouer un peu au chat et à la souris
sur sur certaines sur certaines
disciplines mais voilà le but est
effectivement d'avoir la piste ici à
saint quentin la plus large au monde
avec 8 mètres de large lui met des
autres font quoi cette note entre six
mètres et demi et 7 mettre d'accord si
on l'appelle déjà la piste des records
on l'appelle la piste au record
puisqu'elle est unique au monde par sa
largeur est ce m supplémentaires par
rapport à la moyenne fait que les
athlètes pourront aller gagner des
centièmes et battre des records
potentiellement d'ailleurs on le verra
peut-être aller une figuration puisqu'il
va y avoir un match extrêmement
spectaculaire on a une inauguration de
très haut niveau puisque on a
la revanche de la finale des jo-2002
terre le 30 janvier qui est placé sous
le mode d'une exhibition dont il n'y a
pas de compétition au réel mais on sera
trois semaines un mois des championnats
du monde donc on sait que le haut niveau
et on finit par le on commence par la
meilleure prestation cyclisme mondial
les champions olympiques et les vice
champions olympiques qui sont aussi
parce que la france est championne du
monde quand même donc voilà c'est
vraiment l'un de mes deux meilleures
équipes mondiales alors c'est un projet
qui a commencé à voir avec avec les jeux
olympiques de paris puisque c'était
c'était ici que ray corée
que serait trouvé le vélodrome s'il y
avait eu les jeux olympiques alors ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été
abandonnées après après l'échec de paris
dont sa candidature aux jeux olympiques
pourquoi ça c'est resté assez rester
parce qu'il y avait une très grosse
motivation parlant les élus locaux qui
voulait absolument voir naître ce projet
y avait aussi un besoin quasiment vital
un besoin de fonds de la fédération
française de cyclisme de pouvoir se
doter d'un équipement aujourd'hui le
frisson ils veulent dire voilà depuis le
vel d'hiv y avait pas grand chose il
avait une piste à l'insep à paris bois
de vincennes où finalement il
s'entraînait sur une piste qui faisait
100 mètres de moins que la longueur
normale donc c'est comme si vous aviez
une équipe de foot qui s'entraînent sur
un mineur et puis qui jouent les
compétitions sur un grand terrain et qui
arrive à être quand même championne du
monde dans ces conditions donc voilà
donc le projet a été vraiment porté par
les élus par la fédération par le
groupement vélopolis pour candidater et
puis faire sortir ce projet qui est un
projet complètement atypique ont alors
au curragh y aura le cyclisme de piste
sur cette piste naturelle ya la
fédération de française de cyclisme qui
s'installe aussi ici que voir ses
bureaux et zioui alors juste en dessous
de nous là dans l'est dans les étages la
fédération aura son staff à nice
pratique d'à peu près une centaine de
personnes avec la direction technique
nationale ça lui permet aussi de
rassembler l'ensemble de ces athlètes
puisque avant les athlètes étaient un
peu dispersés en france suivant les
sites de pratique qui était disponible
et ouvert à eux la fédération peut
rassembler ses troupes recréer un esprit
d'équipé puis être dans les meilleures
dispositions pour les médailles et
peut-être fort mais aussi des défusions
champions parce que c'est vrai ce que
vous dire il ya peu de vélo donc on se
demande toujours comment débuter les
églises de piste puisque il ya peu
d'endroits au centre de la route on voit
bien mais la piscine attend beaucoup oui
paradoxalement puisqu'en fait ce qu'on
réalise aujourd'hui c'est que les
meilleurs cyclistes sur piste ce qui
gagne le tour de sur route par dont ceux
qui payent le tour de france ou qui
sont des sprinteurs avec des pistards
c'est pas cela c'est par la piste qu'ils
ont acquis leurs anticipations et leur
élan vélocité et paradoxalement la piste
est un marché de niche en france qu'il
ya très peu de pratiquants nous notre
métier effectivement d'aller faire
découvrir la pratique de la piste à un
maximum de gens et puis derrière de leur
mettre le pied à l'étrier de venir
pratiquer ou pas au futur champion qui
vont naître ici à gruissan quant à l or
donc ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
évidemment les exhibitions évidemment
les champions et médias dans les
entraînements
bdd des québécois mais ouvert à tout le
monde ouvert à tous voilà sire que la
piste est ici qui est donc
conçu bâti pour les records et pour les
athlètes de haut niveau sera également
ouverte à monsieur tout le monde si vous
voulez venir à venir faire un baptême
demain il y aura un coach laurent aïello
et on viendra vous faire faire un tour
de piste et puis aussi d'autres
activités jusque on aura ici au milieu
de leurs centrales des terrains de
badminton en pratique loisir on a une
vocation d'être le centre national du
cyclisme donc les cendres de tous les
jours la piste le bmx avec le derrière
le freestyle pour les plus aguerris ou
les plus fous fous voilà le bike polo
donc le polo à vélo avaient également
qu'il est petit
et puis le badminton des sports de
combat
des séances de fitness également bref
toute une palette d'activités sportives
vous êtes en lien avec d'autres
fédérations
pour voir d'autres sports qui serait
alors on est au rendez vous ici d'autres
fédérations principalement pour
l'événementiel réaliser des finales de
coupe de france où voilà pour ce qui est
des activités quotidiennes on est
complètement autonome c'est-à-dire qu'on
met en place nos propres activités en
relation avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines mais oui on est vu
la nature de l'enceinte je dirais sont
sa configuration technique puisque on
est aux toutes dernières normes de
fibres éthique etc ça attire beaucoup de
gens croient alors il ya le sport et
doyer aussi la culture ou en fin de
spectacle
puisque vous avez courir six minutes
place en 1 6000 places 6043 place
exactement dans le bâtiment donc ce qui
fait de nous la deuxième joueuse
spectateurs indoor après le palais
omnisports de paris bercy la personne ça
sera ou alors la scène sera plutôt au
fond ils font demande si on voit une
rampe d'accès camions qui fera je dirais
99 pourtant % du temps fermée elle ne
sera découverte que pour faire rentrer
des camions donc pour des besoins
spécifiques donc on a une ère qui fait à
peu près de 2700 mètres carrés avec une
tribune une scène qui se positionnera au
fond en fond de salle et qui permettra
d'avoir des gens dans l'air centrale ou
et des gens dans les tribunes d'accord
mais c'est aussi une enceinte qui sert
pour des grosses convention d'entreprise
ou des spectacles on peut imaginer des
dîners au milieu de leurs centrales
pendant que les gens tournent sur la
piste et donc avoir un vrai show sport
spectacle
en savoir beaucoup d'activités
où c'est là on a une idée neuve
fréquentation la fréquentation qu'on a
estimé elle est aux alentours des 300
mille personnes pour la première année
dont à peu près la moitié sur les
activités quotidiennes puisqu'on peut
venir soit pratiqué une fois soit
pratiqué toute l'année à volonté salma
des formules les gens mais le choisit et
puis à peu près la même chose en
configuration concert spectacle et puis
aux alentours il ya tout un complexe
immobilier qui est en train de se
réaliser avec une résidence chercheurs
des bureaux
donc ça va être vraiment un centre de
vie
sorte de vide et des années qui viennent
quoi c'est ce que voulait la ville
opération il voulait surtout pas qu'on
vient de poser un vélodrome est cuit
nulle part elle voulait vraiment recréer
une dynamique sur une partie de la base
de loisirs du territoire qui était un
peu laissé à l'abandon mais beaucoup
moins dynamique que le reste est donc là
on recrée vraiment un cercle de vie avec
presque un millier de personnes qui
d'ici à fin 2015 début 2016 vont venir
vivre ou travailler à progresser il faut
pouvoir un petit coup de chiffres de
l'investissement c'est
l'investissement c'est un investissement
en partenariat public privé donc il ya
une partie en fonds publics le global de
l'investissement c'est 75 millions
d'euros est à peu près les trois quart
financé par le public est à une région
département d'information et puis le
dernier quart par le privé qui finance
également les 27 années d'exploitation
du bâtiment de maintenance et
d'entretien de façon à ce que dans les
27 tonnes dans 27 ans on puisse
restituer le bâtiment à l'agglomération
qu'ils soient dans le même temps comme
neuf ça évite d'avoir à faire supporter
les coûts de maintenance et d'entretien
aux contribuables aujourd'hui j'ai le
drone coûtera pendant 27 ans il coûtera
0 aux contribuables puisque c'est
l'activité privée le fonds de commerce
privée qui est doit équilibrer les les
flux financiers donc vous êtes un des
rares français qui sait ce qui va faire
à peu près dans les vingt-sept en
aiguillettes
personne n'est jamais à l'abri mais oui
j'ai une visibilité
on est là pour ça et on est motivé pour
rester en tout cas c'est un comment on
pourrait arriver ce post pour vous moi
j'étais dans déjà dans l'industrie du
site rejet un parcours plutôt issus du
marketing sportif j'ai commencé ma
carrière dans le marketing du paris
saint germain et puis après je suis
venue sur le territoire et puis j'ai
atterri chez un équipementier
pneumatiques pour la fédération
française du cyclisme est donc d'abord
je suivais le projet en tant que
qu'équipementier avec intérêt et puis au
fur et à mesure des discussions et puis
l'aide la collaboration qu'on a pu
apporter pour essayer de rendre ce lieu
de roubles le plus autonome possible les
bains a fait que j'ai eu une opportunité
pour pour intégrer dans
l'enceinte va écouter on va vous
souhaiter beaucoup de travail encore un
parce qu'on les papilles tout ça est en
bonne voie les délais vont être
respectés donc voilà vous êtes un homme
heureux on est oui c'est une grande
chance merci merci merci et venues